dr. Jana Williams welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me
[Music]
welcome to trigonometry I'm Frances
roster I'm Constance I'm Kissin and this
is the show for you if you're bored of
people arguing on the Internet are the
subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts here at the
world-famous angel comedy club our
amazing expert guest this week is dr.
Joanna Williams who's the author of
women vs feminism and the associate
editor of Spike magazine dr. Johnny
Williams welcome to took an oratory
thank you for having me
[Music]
well thank you so much for coming in
that well you are the author of women vs
feminism let's just get straight into
that I'm assuming that in part in partly
in writing that you've had to define the
word feminism yes what is your
definition well I'm not one with
reluctance I'm not one which I guess in
of itself is a controversial thing to
say as a woman I think it's often
assumed particularly if you're a
educated woman that you automatically
will be a feminist and when I say that
I'm not a feminist I think people think
that that means that I'm all for women
kind of staying at home in the kitchen
having children which is completely the
opposite of what I think I think women
should be out there in the world making
an impact on society preferably changing
the world that's that go along but I
think we don't need feminism to do that
anymore and I think it's gotten to the
point where feminism is really holding
women back because the feminism that
seems to be described as fourth wave
feminism or intersectional feminism but
I think is actually the feminism that
feels guardian columns fills school
assemblies on everyday sexism just seems
to be absolutely determined to tell
women that they're victims that they're
disadvantaged that they're oppressed in
a way that just doesn't match up with
the reality of suddenly of my existence
and of all the women who I know it
doesn't match up with the reality of
their existence and I don't think women
are victims today so that's why I
wouldn't call myself a feminist so
before we dig into that how have you
come to the place that you are now to
have these views to be the person they
are what's been your journey through
life so I guess when I was much younger
I would have described myself as a
feminist suddenly I was brought up to be
a feminist and I was brought up to be
very left-wing
I'm from Middlesbrough in the northeast
of England I grew up as a child thinking
that Margaret Thatcher was the worst
person who'd ever walked on this earth
and was entirely responsible for or the
industry in Middlesbrough coming to an
end and people who I knew
being put out of work so that's very
much my kind of political background but
then I think I began to think about
things a lot more critically and I think
feminism changed and left-wing politics
has changed over the course of the past
twenty thirty years and I think some of
the things that I believed in twenty
thirty years ago like free speech like
the fact that women are strong and
powerful and can do what they want and
those ideas seem to have been abandoned
by the political left and they seem to
have been abandoned by feminism so
that's why I no longer really associate
myself with those ideas so that's why I
wanted sorry friends that's why I wanted
to dig into the definition of feminism
because my understanding of feminism I
think was what you were talking about
which is it's the idea that men and
women are and should be equal right but
there seems to be more to that now so
what would what do you see as the third
or fourth wave feminism that you you you
are reacting against how would you
define that yeah I think that's a really
great question so I think there's two
ways of looking at it I think your apps
you and I've lost track of how many
times over the past couple of years
people have told me oh go and get a
dictionary look at feminism in a
dictionary and you'll see that all it
means is that men and women are equal as
if this is the most kind of benign and
innocent statement in the world and of
course if that was all that feminism
meant then yes we would all be feminists
as the old saying goes but I think it
comes with so much more baggage nowadays
and I think the position of women in
society has changed so I mean just a few
kind of facts and statistics to back
that up if you look I mean girls are
doing so much better at school than boys
nowadays and I know this is quite widely
known but I think what's less well known
is just how long this has been going on
for so more women the men have been
going to university for over quarter of
a century now over 25 years we've had
more women the men going to university
and as a result then you've got more
women entering the professions more
women taking top jobs you've got more
women than men
working as accountants as vets as
doctors as lawyers and because of this
women are earning more than ever before
as well so particularly for women under
the age of 40 the pay gap is absolutely
negligible I mean the our if you compare
hourly rates of pay the median pay gap
is under two percent so I mean it's
really negligible so women's lives have
changed and but but what feminism does
in order to keep going is it can't ever
admit victory it can't ever say yeah
guys you're right you know we we've got
equality or we we've as near as damn it
got equality instead what it does is it
digs up more and more obscure areas of
inequality so it looks further to try
and find areas where you can justifiably
claim that women are still oppressed so
it shifts away from what's going on in
reality jobs and work and it got moves
into culture and it moves into what I
think is looking at men's kind of bad
behavior which a lot of the time isn't
even that bad as far as I'm concerned so
I'm sure you have heard this time last
week a professor from King's College
London made the terrible terrible
mistake of getting into a lift at a
conference in San Francisco and asking
for the ladies lingerie floor and this
has made news headlines around the world
for a week which is absolutely bizarre
this should be the case exactly so -
seems like feminism has gone in this
really bizarre direction where jokes and
speech and whistling and winking
apparently I think it's 36 percent of 18
to 24 year-old women think that winking
on whistling is a form of sexual
harassment and I kind of think it's
really sad that they've been taught to
think that way what wouldn't you say
that there is there is definitely
feminism definitely should still exist
when you think of what is happening
like you for instance issues such as FGM
with the fact that in certain countries
women aren't allowed to vote or they're
not allowed to drive you know they still
live under a rigid patriarchy surely
that doesn't that mean that we should
still have feminism well I think you're
absolutely right that the position of
women and men around the world in
different countries around the world is
very very different actually I think
feminism is far too deferential towards
Islam as a religion and you see very few
feminist campaigns which actually
challenged some of the patriarchal
assumptions of Islam particularly in
countries where Islam is the dominant
religion and I think if the feminists
really were looking for areas of
inequality gender inequality to expose
and the could certainly go a lot further
and deeper in looking at what is going
on in other countries around the world
but it seems to me that particularly in
this country what you have is incredibly
privileged women women who are
presenters at the BBC for example women
whose salaries look like telephone
numbers who are able to make front-page
news stories out of how terrible their
lives are and you know I'm not naive I
certainly don't think that all women
even in this country are doing
fantastically well nowadays and
everything's so super brilliant and we
just want to put a smile on our face and
say hey everything's wonderful you know
I do think there's some women who don't
have it so well but I actually think
that those women have far more in common
with men who are in the same position
and are much better off fighting for
their rights for better pay better
housing better childcare alongside men
who they live with who they work with so
for example one area in society where
there is absolutely zero gender pay gap
is for people who are earning the
minimum wage because if you are in a job
that pays the minimum wage it doesn't
matter if you're a man or a woman you
both get paid the minimum wage so those
people who are on minimum wage jobs are
much better off working alongside each
other to fight for
Oh ages then the women are aligning
themselves with BBC presenters CEOs
footsie 100 companies in kind of saying
this is a specifically an issue that
specifically affects women now you were
saying about just do you think about
Islam and the patriarchal attitudes of
certain Islamic countries do you think
that certainly the the modern feminist
movement is essentially targeting easy
targets instead of going for certain
issues that they know would be divisive
and potentially controversial I think
there's some truth in that but I think
the problem is I think and this is going
to sound really controversial but I
think feminism nowadays is both an
elitist preoccupation and it's
self-obsessed there's a real degree of
narcissism in it so if you look at like
the me to movement this is all about
saying meet Eve you know I'm a victim
too bad things have happened to me as
well and it's about putting themselves
in the center of the story it the
narrative becomes their own victimhood
so rather than looking abroad or even in
this country to looking at other women
who are maybe more disadvantaged than
them this is about us this is about how
disadvantaged I am and and if there's a
real streak of narcissism of making
themselves and their own victimhood
the center of the story let me put a
counter-argument to that because I mean
the it did seem to me that certainly the
Miche movement at points went too far
you know a good example is a comedian
called Aziz Ansari who you probably
remember got into trouble for what
seemed to be like a consents consensual
in a bad day he's a bad day right and
then the conversation seemed to go well
bad dates are also a form of anyway but
he did seem to me certainly that there
were people who ended up being exposed
as a result of the two meeting movement
who were absolutely vile despicable
human beings who were abusing their
power who were taking advantage of women
and men but predominantly women why is
why are you critical of them
government that has allowed a lot of
people although I get what you're saying
it allowed a lot of people to go yes me
too and maybe their their experiences
we're not as bad as someone who might be
a victim of Harvey Weinstein or whatever
but he was a movement that exposed a lot
of bad behavior terrible behavior and it
allowed a lot of people to have
validation that something they were
unable to speak about up to that point
they now were able to speak about why
are you critical well you say it exposed
as if this has been as if these people
have been proven found guilty and I
actually think I'm sure again I'm not
naive I'm sure bad things have happened
and I'm sure people I have your
Weinstein I have no doubt behaved
incredibly badly if not illegally in the
past but they need to be tried in courts
of law you know they need to be found
guilty in a court of law punished and
sentenced appropriately for what they've
done and the problem with the me2
movement is it shifts the debate away
from a court of law and it takes it on
to social media so these become Twitter
campaigns and Facebook campaigns and
what you have then is allegation counter
allegation you get all kinds of blurring
of different experiences all put into
the mix together all contributing to
this narrative that to be female today
is to be quite uniquely oppressed and
abused and meanwhile the likes of Harvey
Weinstein are just seen as one among
many and I think they actually get let
off the hook you know they need they
need to be taken to court and we need to
see these allegations tested well
actually what was you know why is she
not been prosecuted yet I don't know
well any of these people who've got in
trouble right apparently based on
allegations justifiably so why have none
of them been processed aesthetics might
have a bit of respect
I think somebody like Harvey Weinstein I
think there probably are proceedings
underway and I'm sure will no doubt see
him in court before too long but I think
the problem with the movement like as I
said it does drag in a lot of other
people so you mentioned Aziz Ansari
whether there are simply no there's
nothing about that story that could
stand up in a court of law there is
nothing that he did that was in any way
illegal so you just get this kind of
general sense of yuckiness
this was not a nice thing that happened
to this woman and no you have men and
you know I'm not somebody who generally
goes around saying let's feel sorry for
men I've got no time whatsoever for the
men's rights movement but you you do
have men who've had their jobs lost
reputations shattered on allegations
rather than actually haven't been found
guilty of any particular crime I mean I
think there's been a huge shift and I
think if you go back 20 years ago and
more you know women were routinely not
believed women could take stories and
did take stories to the police are not
even stories took accusations to the
police and were not believed and and
justice didn't operate in their favor
and I think that's terrible and that's
not a time that I have any desire to
return to but I think the pendulum has
swung so far the other way now that we
have this assumption that we'll women
should always be believed that women who
make accusations of sexual harassment or
sexual assault never lie and actually I
think that's just as unhelpful as saying
women should never be believed so I'm a
woman and I'm quite capable of lying I
do her live in a burrow
doesn't stop me from trying every now
and again but I think if we have this
assumption that women never lie that
women must always be believed I think it
actually reduces women to the status of
children that were put on this kind of
special pedestal as a kind of this rare
breed apart and actually doesn't do
women any favors at all do you think a
large part of me to campaign was based
in the frustrations of women when it
comes when it comes to things like
conviction rates for sexual assault rape
which are notoriously low and it's
incredibly difficult to prove so so for
some women the only option they felt
they have the only power they have is to
go on social media and go this happened
to me yeah not completely convinced I'm
afraid I think conviction rates for
sexual assault it's very very difficult
to say they are loved
because what you're assuming then is
that there's a lot of cases where they
what should have been found guilty but
weren't found guilty so you're kind of
reading something in then to non
statistics you're looking at a lack of
allegation or a lack of successful
conviction and reading into that
something that we can never ever know
over whether it's actually there or not
you know I'm not really explaining that
very clearly but we're we're saying that
this is a huge problem because there are
no statistics to back it up and I'm
always very very doubtful about doing
that
I'm also very doubtful about women who
say they are so completely powerless
they had to spill all in the front page
of The Times you know my only option so
if you look at this woman in the lift in
San Francisco you know what essentially
what she's saying is that she felt so
exhausted is the word that she actually
is actually used she was so exhausted by
having to deal with sexism on a routine
basis that she was completely unable to
say there and then in the left actually
that's a really crap joke it's not even
funny and I find it offensive which
personally I think would have been an
overreaction anyway but she was so
exhausted by sexism that she couldn't
say that yet she was able to go off
making an efficient official complaint
and drag the whole thing through pages
of newspapers my girlfriend do you think
John is about people's lack of
understanding of statistics because I
know from speaking to many women my wife
included that many many women I would I
would argue probably the vast majority
of women have experienced some form of
harassment of one shape or form or
another but that does not necessarily
mean that the majority of men are doing
the harassing the 80/20 rule would tell
us that actually probably it's a small
minority of men who are doing a lot of
the harassment which many women
experience and then put the picture then
becomes men are harasses women are being
harassed and there's this conflict do
you think that we are it's just a
misunderstanding of statistics basically
what I'm asking no I don't think it's
misunderstanding of statistics because I
think people interpret and even look for
statistics that back up a particular
narrative but they want to present to
the world I think one thing that has
happened is that definitions of
harassment and you see this with in
domestic violence with even with rape
itself definitions change over time and
they expand and they are very subjective
definitions so the one thing that I
think the me2 movements really thrown up
is that the definition of harassment
according to the proponents of me2 is
unwanted behavior it's it's anything
that you don't want to happen is labeled
as harassment so this is why you get
things like winking and whistling being
interpreted a sexual house and
particularly by younger people so
there's nothing objective I I don't
think there's anything in a wink that is
objectively abusive or
thing to you it's how you feel about
that wink and how you feel about the
person who's winking at you so you've
got these kind of very subjective very
elastic definitions so then when we come
out with statistics like you know
sometimes I've seen 85 90 percent of
women have experienced harassment and if
you're a young woman especially like oh
my god that's appalling you know so this
you must just walk down the street and
it's just like a barrage of harassment
from the moment you leave your house and
if you read 90% of women that is what
you're gonna think but then dig down and
like say if harassment is being winked
at you know or being whistled at then
you know really is this really such a
well she's something sorry Frances let
me just ask this one this is something I
will really wanted to ask you because
and it's a bit of a complicated point so
let me lay it out how much of this but
is about the biological differences
between men and women and here's my
point men a bigger stronger more
aggressive more prone to violence on
average right then women are do we can
we agree as long as we put in the on
average statistics tell us men commit
more way more violent friends yeah but I
think perhaps women just perhaps use
aggression of violence in different ways
let's say okay physically but I don't
think men are controlled by their
testosterone and I think to say that if
we start off with men on average a
bigger stronger more prone to physical
aggression and violence right as I'm
putting that out there and you don't
have to agree but if we take that for
the point of this argument right if you
then look at if I put myself in that
position say I'm I don't five foot nine
or something right I'm not particularly
strong or big or what
if a guy another guy who I knew was
sexually interested on me who was much
bigger much stronger who I perceived as
being prone to way more aggression than
I am prone to Francis was big and strong
so if that was the scenario and say we
were in an isolated environment right if
Francis was to wink at me
in a dark alley he was bigger and have
very good eyesight I would my reception
of that would differ based on the
comparative size and strength difference
between the two of us so how much of it
is that women tend to be smaller they
tend to be weaker and therefore less
able to defend themselves you add on top
of that the fact that given the
historical situation men tend to be in
positions of power more than women are
at this point in time so then you've got
the potential situation where someone
who's bigger stronger and in a position
to influence your career is making what
might be perceived outside of that
context as relatively innocuous
suggestive you know winking whatever but
if you put all that together
it's hinting at a problem which is
you're not really fully able to defend
yourself and stand up for yourself in
that situation yeah not convinced I'm
afraid but I wanted to lay that out
because a lot of the people who may be
watching this will be having these
thoughts and that's what we'd like to do
at trigonometry we like to bring in
interesting controversial people and
then pose questions to them that I think
a lot of people would want to have
definitely no well I I mean you're
asking right at the very very beginning
about my kind of political background
and what motivates me politically
and I think one belief that I've had for
twenty years as long as I can remember
or I don't know about a belief but one
thing that I've instinctively reacted
against
is any form of determinism whether that
is a social determinism so I am how I am
because my mother dressed me in pink
baby grows and I was given a doll to
play with or at the same time a
biological determinism I am how I am
simply because of my hormones and you
know I instinctively reacted against
both of those things because both of
those things are saying that I'm not in
control of myself you know I am Who I am
because of other things that happened to
me or what I happen to be born with and
I think the problem with the argument
that you've put forward is that it
suggests that it's it's promised on this
idea that men are ruled by their
testosterone that men are potential and
grasses let's take that question
no no but simply because men are men
women should be fearful of men and I
have to say you know I know men of all
different shapes and sizes who are more
or less aggressive and there's no
connection between physical size and
power and aggression you don't think
there's a connection between someone
being bigger and stronger and them being
more threatening no no absolutely not I
mean I really don't think that people
are programmed in that way I don't think
I mean perhaps if we were living back in
cavemen times and we were carrying on in
society as if our kind of animal
instinct was coming to the fore
then perhaps but if you think about the
way we encounter other people nowadays
it's not in the raw like that it tends
to be in officers in workplaces on
transport etc and I don't think women
are kind of automatically shying away
from men based on their physical
appearance do you think that one of the
positives of the Mito campaign because
of course are positive and negatives to
every campaign so it's certainly exposed
a certain boorishness and some men's
behavior such as cat calling for
instance I know the argument be why
should a woman walk down the street and
be
called I mean that is intimidation isn't
it really having a group of men leering
and shouting at you do you know I mean I
wonder what kind of world this happens
in I mean building sites which is always
their kind of stereotypical argument
that this is where this goes on you know
that poor women can't possibly walk past
building sites without men latching at
them and whistling at them building
contractors actually have written into
their contracts nowadays that they are
not allowed to do this and this has been
the case for many yar and you know maybe
it's just me you're a beautiful woman
I'm saying you've never experienced I'd
say never but it's a lot less usual than
it once was and you could say well are
you know I'm ten ten years old obviously
then I was 10 years ago but I think this
idea that to be a woman is just just to
confront this constant barrage of
harassment you know I don't think that's
true
dude you have to put up with even a
single incident because not every woman
hates it you know I can certainly vow I
can suddenly say that there have been
times when I fought down the street and
somebody whistles at you and this is
probably a terrible thing to admit that
puts a spring in feeling a bit happier
than I did but essentially what you're
talking about is interaction between men
and women and you think well where do we
go then if we want to stamp out these
spontaneous interactions so I know
Labour MPs have proposed a new law in
the houses of parliament that cat
calling in the street should be outlawed
as a misogynistic hate crime so what you
do then how do you police that how much
police time energy money do you put into
having a policeman a woman standing on
every street corner kind of spotting the
rogue Whistler and going up to give him
a slap around the wrist you know that
that's not something I would I
particularly would see as a priority I'd
rather they were out catching you people
with knives who are going to commit
knife crime than random wolf whistlers
so then people say well it's not a
question of having police
standing on the corner it's a question
of Education so again you know what do
we want do we want teachers in schools
to say well I could teach you about the
history of the Tudors and the stewards
but actually I'm not I'm gonna sit down
and we're gonna react eight you all know
about the correct way for boys and girls
to behave in relation to each other you
know actually I think having spontaneity
is not a bad thing and letting men and
women have free speech interact is not
the worst thing in the world on the
whistling on the cat calling you know I
actually think women are quite capable
of giving as good as they get and
certainly in the past year I made a joke
and I said there's been time and wasn't
a joke it was true that there's times
when it's put smile on my face and I've
walked down the street happy there's
also been times I've been quite capable
of turning around and telling someone
just to [ __ ] off and leave me alone and
they have done they've been quite
shocked and they have left me alone and
I don't think I'm like some rare type of
special woman who's got these magic
powers because I'm capable of telling a
man to [ __ ] off you know I know plenty
of other women
[Laughter]
[Music]
you mentioned a little bit about the
gender pay gap and you said that it
isn't as large as has been intimated by
some feminists could you go into that a
little bit well first yeah definitely so
the gender pay gap I think is a really
really good example of how statistics
can be used to prove anything that you
want them to prove at all because it all
depends on what we measure so if you
want to make the gender pay gap seem
massive then what you do is you look at
the earnings of all men and the earnings
of all women and you compare them with
each other and surprise surprise you
find out that women earn less than men
but obviously what that's not taking
into account is the hours that men and
women work the jobs that men and women
do and this fact that we've already
mentioned you know in the past men and
women weren't as equal as they are today
so if you look at the top rungs of
careers where people have been working
for 30 40 years they've reached the
absolute top of their profession you are
more likely to find men in those
positions so if you do that you take all
men's wages all women's wages you find a
very very big gender pay gap but
basically the more we compare like for
like so the more you look at men and
women doing the same jobs for the same
number of hours for the same level of
experience then the pay gap gets
narrower and narrower and narrower and
eventually comparing like for like it
disappears or together there's no gender
pay gap if you look at men and women who
are both doing the same job same length
of time same number of hours each week
and of course that's the case I mean you
just think about this for like a minute
or two because for one thing it's
illegal so if you took two people who
are doing the exact same job exact same
hours exact same level and the man was
being paid more the woman could take
this company the boss to court you know
it would be illegal that would be
breaking the law but but there's an even
more common-sense argument as well if if
bosses could get away with paying women
substantially less for doing the exact
same workers as men do but but just
cheaper you
why would any boss anywhere ever employ
a man you know why would you get a man
to do the job well it's interesting that
you say that because we're recording
this and by the time this goes out it'll
be a couple of weeks from today probably
the guest whose episode we've just
released is a lady called dr. Pittman
Mangrum who's a good friend and a
wonderful person she's a former adviser
to an American president founder of her
own company etc and when we talked to
her we asked her about the pay gap as
well and she said that as a speaker
after her political career and all the
rest of it she actually had her own
agent speaking agent say to her your
metrics are great you're getting better
performances than your male counterparts
but we cannot get you the same fees
because you're a woman so there is there
is some I mean not everyone is rational
not everyone I mean you say it's illegal
and it is but people do illegal stuff
all the time right so there's probably a
small element of the discrimination that
is part of what causes the gender pay
gap but I totally hear your argument
about these averages being useless
essentially in measuring the real gender
pay gap but I so my question you think
there's no discrimination against women
all in a way I mean I I don't know the
woman who you've you've just interviewed
number allele watch that interview with
great interest but I mean some possible
advice from me to her you know and I'm
sure she probably won't watch and won't
appreciate this but if I was her I'd say
she's not anyway she's not someone who
would whine or complain she took action
i sacked that agent get yourself another
right my point is she's a very very
accomplished very powerful person who's
who's made great success of her life not
every person is I'm not as accomplished
or successful and I'm you know so
they're not everyone is capable of
necessarily of that not everyone is in a
position where their value is so high
then they can do that definitely well I
think there's a couple of things to say
here I mean for one thing I think that
when we compare means that we we hear on
the news you know about bp's women who
work at the BBC being paid a lot less
than men said there was even a story
about Martina Navratilova
/ when she was doing the commentary at
the Liddy Wimbledon the tennis have been
paid less than I can be on board no
McEnroe John McEnroe doing likewise
doing the coverage of Wimbledon but then
you stop and you look at this you know
McEnroe was a much bigger personality he
was the one who was fronting the BBC's
coverage he was doing ten times as much
a lot of live broadcasts as Navratilova
was so again you just were not comparing
like for like and the way the story
appears is like oh poor Martina
Navratilova isn't it terrible
Orvis discrimination so we had know the
story about Claire Foy and Matt Smith in
the crown you know Claire Foy was being
paid less than Matt Smith isn't this
terrible she was in the lead role at
cetera et cetera
apart from before the crown who had
heard of Claire Foy you know not me
whereas Matt Smith had been Doctor Who
so when we talk about speakers
celebrities sports stars their salaries
are not worked out in the same way age I
mean if you are working in McDonald's
and you sell you know actually I'd like
to negotiate a pay raise yeah good luck
with that the door this is not to say
that I don't think there's any truth in
what you're saying I do think that
there's a perhaps a confidence issue for
women where they are less likely to push
themselves forward perhaps undervalue
themselves you know I've certainly been
in cases particularly when I speak
American universities and they'll ask me
well what's your going rate and I'm like
oh my god I have no idea how to answer
this question and the fear is if you are
my fear is you pitch yourself too high
they're gonna say no thank you and laugh
and you're underselling myself as a
result but you know what I think
feminism today doesn't help women with
that confidence problem I think the more
we hear it's so [ __ ] being a woman it's
so awful the more you do then begin to
undervalue yourself you you think then
when people undervalue you you think oh
yes this is just what life's like for
being a woman because it's really awful
and terrible so I think
best thing feminism could do for women
would be to say actually there's loads
of opportunities out there never been a
better time to be a woman get out there
take advantage of all these
opportunities don't sit at home
underselling yourself this is a very
very good point
I mean if we just can focus a little bit
on Aging now I mean I mean to me ageism
is what is one of the prejudices we that
is simply accepted in our society it's
acceptable I've heard you know I've seen
especially on social media supposedly
Bruce got what would he know he's just
an old man yeah experience counts for
nothing do you think that the ageism is
particularly more how can I put this
it's been more severe when it comes to
women than it is to MIT than it is for
men do you know what I think it is but I
think a lot of that comes from other
women it comes from younger women and
particularly comes from younger
feminists so I think for one thing that
there is a whole lack of appreciation
for what some of the second wave
feminism of the battles that second wave
feminists someone about people like
Germaine Greer you know what the the
battles that they had to win and the
successes that women can enjoy today as
a result of the efforts of those second
wave feminists is is really shocking the
lack of appreciation and the insults
that are thrown and not just on social
media but even in the pages of The
Guardian it's quite acceptable it seems
to describe older second wave feminists
as lobotomized you know that's just
quite an everyday statement but if you
take somebody like the French film star
Catherine Deneuve as she came out and
criticized me too
she was completely slated for this you
know this was shock horror you know
she's a traitor to the cause how could
this woman you know she's clearly being
lobotomized stupid old woman how can she
come out and say these things and that
was feminists who were giving all this
criticism to her you know in the night
seventies Catherine Deneuve wrote
another letter to French newspapers she
wrote a letter a signatory to a letter
that said I have had an abortion and
that was at a time when abortion was
illegal in France so not only was it
morally taboo but it was breaking the
law as well she signed that letter and
in signing that letter she helped bring
about a change in the law and it just
seems ironic that when she wrote that
letter 40 years ago it was the French
establishment who came down on her who
insulted her who you know what were
treated her really badly 40 years later
it's feminists who were treating her in
that way
you know insulting her and there's no
sense of well actually maybe we should
pay a bit of respect to a woman who
helped bring about some of the major
gains that we've got today it's
interesting they bring that up because
last week we interviewed Tatchell the
gay rights activist and this is the
question that I put them I mean do you
not when people are like trying to not
put no platform you and call you you are
bigger there must be a part of you that
just goes how do I mean it's incredible
that anyone would even try to just mean
but in terms of that what do you make of
this whole approach where we're no
longer really having conversations
anymore it's just if you don't agree
with me your ex phobic you are this your
that you're a bigger your your
misogynistic your whatever so for
example you can try and have a
conversation about the gender pay gap
from a purely numbers point of view
without any personal involvement at all
yeah good luck with that yes
that's my point so what do you make of
this of the state of debate in our
society today terrible I do I think it's
really bad
I mean you know go back a long long way
to when I was at school if if I took
part in debates or if we had discussion
classes maybe in my English lessons or
something like that we kind of were
taught that ad hominem was a really
cheap form of attack if you are taking
part in a debate that this wasn't the
right way to go but you had to look at
what people were saying think carefully
and respond to their arguments and it
seems as if it's completely the opposite
it's the case nowadays that identity
politics means it's quite fair enough to
judge people just on the basis of their
physical appearance so the phrase I
really really hate and one of the many
phrases I really really hate is check
your priveledge and check your
priveledge really means shut up because
it means we're making all kinds of
assumptions about you based just on what
you look like and on the basis of what
you look like we've determined that
you've got kind of X number of privilege
points therefore you are not allowed to
have a point of view or you're not
allowed to express that point of view
whatever you're gonna say is invalid
just because of who you are and I think
that's that it closes down debate it's
censorious and it means though that we
never actually engage with one another's
ideas because we're just making
assumptions based on on prejudice
essentially and what do you think we
might be overreacting like a lot of
these young people I mean in my head I'm
still about twenty-two waiting the other
week because I went and I did a student
gig a comedy gig at a university and I
came there thinking well I'm a few years
older than these guys and I turned up
when they look about 12 how much of it
is it we're just forgetting that these
people are young people who are
idealistic as we once were probably
they're a little bit naive they don't
have quite a lot of life experience and
they're trying to make their mark in the
world and which really everything is
pretty great anyway so if they want to
change the world they really have to you
know focus on these tiny little issues
in many cases do you think we're
forgetting that these are just kids and
they need to have their own moment yeah
I mean um I suddenly hate the label
snowflake and it's not something that I
like applying to young people and I
think you know we should be try to be a
bit more positive about young people
learner and I suddenly think that
idealism is not to be knocked and I
think the idea that young people are
idealistic that they want to change the
world that they want to make the world a
better place is actually something to
celebrate but at the same time I think
there's a real risk that
we patronize them in in doing that and I
think actually engaging with their ideas
on a political level and saying have you
not realized the problems with the line
in which you're arguing I think is a
good thing to do and I think that
actually shows a lot more respect for
young people rather than just kind of
giving them a metaphorical pat on the
back and saying isn't that sweet that
you've wanted judge people on their
appearance I think actually saying you
know have you thought it in your
aspiration to equality is a good one but
have you thought that you're maybe going
about it the wrong way that there's some
problems with what you're arguing and I
think for me the problem nowadays isn't
really young people as such but more the
fact that an older generation kind of
patronizes them and confirms the worst
in them if you like the worst instincts
of young people I mean who doesn't want
to shut up people they disagree with I
mean there's plenty of people I disagree
with who I would love to secretly not
[Laughter]
just a band and make go cry you know I
think for all I'm saying there's not not
instincts in people you know I do think
that is you don't like what somebody's
saying you go with Francis I think part
of growing up and maturing is that you
realize that you can't just make bad
ideas go away by wishing them away or by
telling people just to shut up you know
you have to engage you have to take
place in the arguments and I think the
problem for young people nowadays is
that they're not allowed to go through
that maturation process because people
are just saying oh yes you're absolutely
right if you don't like these bad ideas
you're totally right we should just make
them go away and if you want to ban them
that's right we'll we'll let you ban
these bad ideas do you find it quite
worrying that the term free speech is
now being associated more and more with
the far right with people like Katie
Hopkins and Tommy Robinson and so on and
so forth that does worry me enormous Lee
I think it's
it's appalling and shocking that that's
the case and I think it's a real
abdication of the left that the left has
kind of abandoned free speech to the
right I don't think I mean for one thing
I think it's hypocritical I don't think
the right in politics whatever that
means nowadays but I don't believe that
the right are big proponents of free
speech and you look back through history
it was traditionally it was the right
that I say if you look at McCarthyism
for example in the u.s. it was the right
to that wanted to censor and to clamp
down on free speech and it was the left
who recognized that they needed free
speech for every major political gain
that we've had in the past 100 what the
past forever has come about through free
speech rather than through censorship
and it was the civil rights movement it
was all these these political struggles
of the left traditionally have needed
free speech and and the left should own
free speech the left should be saying
you know free speech is is our principle
and we want we do still have further to
go to make the world a better place as
far as I'm concerned though there's
still things that that could be done and
we need free speech to be able to win
more political victories in the future
whereas instead it seems to me that the
left's just gone like that right hands
up surrender people on the right that
Katie Hopkins the Tommy Robinson's if
you want free speech you can have it we
want bans and censorship to get our way
and that is really makes me feel
physically sick I mean I think that is
so horrible and I think it puts
left-wing people in a really awkward
situation because you then appear to
have these horrible bedfellows people
who it never in a million years want to
be getting into bed with and yet that
seems to be who people who are arguing
for free speech now automatically appear
to be allowed to
and that's tragic but unfortunately
that's politics you know and you have to
kind of hold you know I think and still
stand up for what you believe in
irrespective of who else tries to
pretend they're on your side and why do
you think the left is unwilling to to
stand up for free speech because I mean
Peter Tatchell who as I said we
interviewed that the week his point was
exactly the point that you've just made
which is in his time when he was at the
beginning of his fight for equality for
the gay people okay women etc he was
fighting almost for free speech first
because that was the method by which you
then achieved the equality for for
people why is the left which is so
focused on ensuring everyone's
well-being which are all great ideals
taking care of everybody such minority
groups why have they abandoned the
pursuit of free speech as the method by
which you achieve those things and has
resorted to censorship and almost
authoritarianism for some extent and
well great question I mean I think for
one thing I'm resorting to
authoritarianism is a damn sight easier
then to actually fighting for free
speech because if you're on a university
campus for example it's a lot easier to
go and run to the vice-chancellor the
head of student experience whoever and
say I don't want this speaker to come
onto my campus than it is to actually
have the arguments out with the person
who's coming who you disagree with so on
the one hand I think it's just a bit
intellectually lazy you know it's easier
to call for a band to call for
censorship and you can have the kind of
moral righteousness on your side when
you're doing that then it is to actually
win the arguments I think there's
something far more fundamental even than
just intellectual laziness to believe in
free speech is to believe in people as
far as I'm concerned it's to believe
that people can be trusted because I
think we make a mistake if we think that
free speech is just about the rights of
the person who wants to talk to me free
speech is far more about the right of
people who want to hear a particular
argument being put forward and if you
believe that then you have to believe
that people are capable of hearing
arguments not here
arguments and turning into some kind of
moronic mob who just act out in a
robotic way you know if they're here
somebody from the far right they're
going to automatically be brainwashed
and like think completely uncritically
and just turn into some far-right person
themselves you need to have some faith
that people are capable of hearing
arguments of dealing with things that
they disagree with of reaching their own
conclusions that people are
fundamentally sensible you think a lot
of it plays into the fact that people
are scared because people nowadays are
terrified of being labeled a racist or
sexist or homophobic spose yourself to
views that deemed to be in inverted
commas controversial you may realize
you're not as secure in your own
opinions as you thought you were and
actually it turns out that you can
change your mind and I think people
worry about changing their mind and
changing your mind is difficult and a
painful thing to do yeah I think there's
a lot of truth in what you'll say and
you know I think it comes back down to
this idea that it is easier to ban
things and I think there is a real fear
of being accused of racism of sexism of
how this might how you might appear to
be in the outside world and and you know
I think standing up for free speech
standing up for what you believe in it's
not easy you know and I kind of wish
sometimes it was a lot easier to do this
but but I think you do have to
ultimately have the courage of your
convictions and and fight for what you
believe in and do you feel that you
personally have an extra responsibility
on that front because you're a woman and
you get more of what you don't get as
much of a hearing as perhaps you feel
you deserve but you get more of a fair
hearing than say a man standing up and
saying exactly the same things as you
are yeah I think that's true
I definitely think that's true I don't
know about whether it gives me more
responsibility or not but I definitely
think I'm I think a challenge to
feminism that comes from a
is perhaps taken more seriously or maybe
not taking more seriously I wish to take
more seriously perhaps less difficult to
ignore that's me yes ma'am I mean I'm
very wide that if men were to say what I
say about things like the gender pay gap
or especially about the me2 movement
then they would just be written off well
of course they're saying that they're
men they're defending their own
interests they're just irredeemably
sexist and terrible people whereas if I
say it it's it is less difficult for
people to to ignore the hands yeah I
think that's a fantastic place to wrap
up it's been a great conversation before
we let you go Jonah just one question we
always like to ask our guests and feel
free to go anywhere you want with this
at all is there one thing that you think
no one's talking about that we really
ought to be talking about today I think
I didn't about not talking about it but
something that to me I think is an
increasingly big issue and I know it's
the one thing that I say at the moment
in a lifetime spent saying lots and lots
of controversial things the thing that
people really have the biggest problem
with me saying is criticizing University
consent classes and sex and
relationships education in schools and I
think there's so much emphasis on and it
comes from me too and it comes from
feminism and it also comes from this
belief that people are stupid and
ignorant and left to their own
Department you can't argue with people
to their own devices and they just abuse
and rape each other and you need someone
to step in and actually tell young men
that raping people is wrong I mean it's
bizarre because we don't tell them that
murdering people is wrong we kind of
assume that they have enough of a moral
compass to know that murdering people is
wrong and yet there's this idea that
there is a correct way to conduct your
sex life there's a correct way to
negotiate getting someone into bed with
you and we have to teach young people
these kind of scripts to rehearse in the
bedroom and I think that's going
completely on criticizing that is a
conversation that really badly needs to
be had fantastic starting well your book
is called women versus family your
latest book is called women vs feminism
you're on Twitter at Joe Williams 293
Joe Williams 293 I'm Constance and kiss
and I'm ad constant and Kissin I'm
Francis Foster I'm at failing human and
thank you very much for watching the
podcast or listening to it if you've
enjoyed it please give us a rating five
stars say something nice tell a friend
about it we are on iTunes and we are on
what's new on the pocket one pocket cast
I think is it pocket cost I'll get on
that
yep producer doesn't know either we're
screwed
yeah just looking at as blankly that's
what happens when we're out and of
course we're on YouTube do subscribe to
our YouTube channel we put it out an
episode every week and this has been a
fantastic episode thank you so much for
coming thank you very much
[Music]